now in grits we allow any entity
definition to have a physics object that
is an entity doesn't inherit from
physics object and isn't required to
have one eat now for those daring
digital souls who want one they'll need
to actually create a handle to the
physics body and keep it around over
time so they can manipulate it before
they can that of course they have to
first fill out the entity definition
object and pass that out to the G
physics engine add body which we've
coded up previously now for grits every
object in the world in is a box sore
description is pretty easy to generate
first off we pass the x and y position
values to the class alongside the half
width and half height of the box
representing its size in addition to
that box2d expects some specific surface
properties such as dampening friction
things along those lines so we go ahead
and set them here as well if we want
them